hi everyone let's get started before we
get started in this session I wanted to
just briefly get a view of the audience
that we have here how many of you are
Microsoft employees a lot of how many of
you already know who Steve is a couple
how many of you do Python as part of
your daily work so all of you at the
minimum by the end of this presentation
should add Steve to your favorites list
on your Skype for business because Steve
along with the chair of this event Brett
are two of the Python experts here in
Microsoft who to the best of the degree
are available to help you figure out how
to use Python best within Microsoft I
think that is the purpose of this
presentation to show you how to use
Python with Visual Studio and the
understanding that as part of your work
in Visual Studio you may need to use
Python more effectively than you are
right now so without much further ado it
is my pleasure to introduce Steve dower
who will be telling you about Python in
Visual Studio let's give them a round of
applause thank you so how many people
are aware of Visual Studio 2017 which
was released fairly recently this year
2017 kind of gives you the hint this is
the latest iteration of Visual Studio to
come out of developer division at
Microsoft which I'm now part of again my
my team is the core Python team at
Microsoft we bounce around a bit but
we've ended up back and develop a
division working on Python tooling for a
whole lot of things and that includes
visual studio so Visual Studio 2017 is
the latest iteration of Visual Studio
and it's the first to come with what's
known as this concept of workloads now
if you are familiar with and have
installed it this will be a revision for
those who are new this is the Visual
Studio installer it looks very different
from how it used to in the past because
typically in the past you'd get some
very very basic options of here are here
is Visual Studio all you know 15 20
gigabytes worth of it and here's a
couple of optional components that you
can add
remove but essentially you're going to
get 15 gigabytes of value and you know
use a little bit of it and you don't
have much choice Visual Studio 2017 we
completely refactor the installer tour
the entire product apart built it back
up again from small components and gave
you the opportunity to install as little
or as much as you like the bare minimum
install for visual studio these days is
under one gigabyte some of the cache
files will take it up over one gigabyte
but the actual install is much much
smaller than it used to be what do you
get for that install you get the editor
you get textmate syntax highlighting so
most languages are going to have some
basic syntax highlighting it's not quite
the level of rosalyn or Python tools of
Visual Studio but you do get enough to
be able to edit stuff and it starts up
really fast and it's still a good editor
so then you get workloads workloads are
the way that you say this is how I want
to use my visual studio I want to
customize it here are the things that I
want to install to make visual studio
work best for me and they're largely
designed around scenarios so the first
one you first three you'll see here are
all windows focused the universal
Windows platform development workload
dotnet desktop development desktop
development with C++ if you pick the
second one of those dotnet development
you'll get done that development you
don't get C++ you don't get path then
you don't get anything that isn't done
that if you pick C++ you get C++ you
don't get net you don't get a c-sharp
compiler this is the first time we've
ever shipped a copy of Visual Studio
without a c-sharp compiler so if that's
what you want to install that's what you
can choose and of course you can select
both these are check boxes so if I tick
both of these I'll get both now I know
that's not the one you're interested in
so let's scroll down a little bit and
here are two new very interesting
options that have never been seen before
in Visual Studio
there is a Python development workload
and the second is the data science and
analytical applications workload for
anyone who installed Visual Studio 2017
the day that it came out you wouldn't
have seen these these showed up a little
bit later on but if you've got it now
you can go back and check these boxes to
get
this support what do these come with so
the data science and analytical
applications workload to come over to
the right hand side there's more check
boxes this is the top level introduction
this is how you get into the workload
but then there's options you don't have
to take everything that comes with the
workload and you do get to see what's
included reading down the list
it comes with f-sharp support it comes
with Python support it comes with our
support each of these are optional if
you don't actually want F sharp support
you can get rid of it if you don't want
python support you know I don't like you
very much if you don't want our support
you can get rid of it I work on the
fighting support so I'm very
enthusiastic about that I suspect most
people who are here in the room are but
again if you're a data scientist you
need all the tools that we can provide
and so we want to give you all the tools
upfront so that they're there when you
need them in some cases f-sharp is going
to be the right tool for the job we want
you to have it some cases are is the
right tool for the job we want you to
have it these check boxes make sure that
you have what you need going a little
further down we're going to give you
some of the big package bundles for
these languages anaconda is they're
normally selected by default I've
deselected it for a reason I mentioned
later but we'll give you anaconda by
default when you install this you want
all of the Python data science packages
it's just there we'll just lay it down
on your machine let you have it everyone
in this room knows what Anika who
doesn't know what anaconda is two layers
don't know what anaconda is anaconda is
the main thing that your company makes
and gives away sir
that's the one yeah and we also have the
the Microsoft bundle for our which
includes both of these include a curated
set of packages that are most useful for
getting going and they both have the
opportunity to install more packages as
you need them later on and finally
there's a few more options that are
unselected the cookie cutter templates
support is cookie cutter is an open
source project the web that lets people
publish templates onto github and then
makes it really easy to pull them down
Stan she ate them this integration
individual studio for that that comes as
part of this workload
web support from Python is separate if
you're going to be building websites
working in HTML Javascript as well we
keep that separate you can save a couple
of gigabytes of disk space by not
installing that if you know you're not
going to need it but we think you're
going to need it so we'll put it down
for you and if you are likely to be
building your own native extensions for
Python we have stuff to help with that
as well including the compilers so if
you select that option you'll be able to
pip install whatever packages you need
for Python 3 5 and later and it will be
able to build them because the compilers
are there if you've already installed
Visual Studio and you don't have that
anymore
and you need to get back to it later on
the way to do that is to search for
Visual Studio installer you'll find that
in Start menu and that will get you back
into the installer if you heard
installed Visual Studio before didn't
select the Python stuff didn't select
the art stuff didn't select those
options this is going to get you back in
the installer and let you modify your
install to add it or to add a second
installation of Visual Studio so one of
the other big changes that came out of
the work of rebuilding the installer is
the ability to have multiple copies of
Visual Studio installed at the same time
side by side so you can get the latest
preview and install it without affecting
your main install you can have both of
them and choose which one you want to
use depending on what time of day it is
so anyone have any questions about
installers before I move on to the
actual tooling I do scientific computing
and I have C or C++ library I'm
depending on joining another workload so
the question is if I'm working on C
libraries or have a need for C compilers
there are two ways to get those under
under this workload there is the Python
native development tools this includes
the set of C compilers needed for C
Python so if you are building native
extension modules as well as some
templates some extra functionality is
included this will include the compilers
if you need a broader set of tooling for
a native code then I would also come up
to the work word for a desktop
development with C++ this has a much
larger list of optional components all
to do with native development including
if you want the clang support that we've
been working on so that you can take
code written to build with clang and
build it using the Microsoft compiler to
work with other libraries on the machine
there's extra features for C++ like that
and of course anything else that you may
want to do with Visual Studio you can
simply add on anything else before yes
that's generally fine so the question is
I already had anaconda installed and I
selected the option to install it again
you probably got a second copy of it
that's generally going to be fine
there are some cases where they may
conflict newer versions of anaconda will
not they've been steadily improving
their side of things to make sure that
conflicts don't happen and I'll show you
some of those in a little bit when I get
to the product but that's generally
going to be okay
assuming you have enough disk space if
you've already got it installed you
don't need to install it again but
there's no harm in doing it last call
okay so let's jump into visual studio
and there's a very early concept that I
want to make you aware of and in fact
before I get too much further into the
product let's talk about the aims of
this session because I haven't run
through those yet everyone's reading the
code on the screen aren't they let me
get rid of that that's not important
right now
I can see everyone's eyes working
somewhere else no code on the screen
this is Visual Studio now everyone looks
disappointed I'll come back to that code
later on it's also going to be available
for you so you'll be able to get a copy
of it and work through it at your own
pace on your own time so so the aims of
this session I want you to feel
comfortable in visual studio
particularly if you're coming from a
different IDE different background if
you've ended up in Visual Studio for
some reason you've been told that's
that's the IDE to use that's the tools
to use I want you to feel comfortable in
that I'm not necessarily here to
convince you that you should use Visual
Studio I'm not here to pitch it and sell
it to you because I know there's far too
many people that have it forced on them
who then hate it because they can't use
it effectively so what I'm really keen
to do is help you walk through the
things that you may want to change about
Visual Studio the concepts that no one
ever explains properly to you and try
and explain some of the basic concepts
the Visual Studio assumes to help you
understand how you can either
your work flow to it or adapt Visual
Studio to your workflow so that you can
get the most out of it to that end the
rough outline is first I'm going to talk
about projects which if you're not a
visual studio user you have some idea in
your head and I can almost guarantee
that doesn't match what visual studio
thinks projects are so we'll spend a bit
of time on that to try and straighten
those up I'm going to spend a decent
amount of time going through the
customization that's available in visual
studio because being able to adapt it to
work for you is one of the most powerful
features that it has and it's one of the
least talked about ones that it has so
most people are unaware just how much
you can make visual studio work the way
you want it to and make it put things
where you want them to be then I'm going
to get into some of the Python and our
specific functionality let you know
what's there let you know about some of
the secret keyboard shortcuts that
aren't always obvious and let you see
for yourself how that may work into your
process if you end up in a position
where visual studio is your IDE of
choice or against your will question
back there
my question whatever it's like
sterilization got everything in stuff
like Sarafina like to launch this on
well where you can put in your what
you're going to need for a simple for
UNICEF a zombie people through your
logic Alfonzo actually put down all the
information later workspaces like that
[Music]
so I will get to showing you some of
that later on it's probably not going to
be in the next three minutes but
certainly in the next 90 minutes and
again we're kind of in an interesting
transitional position where there's a
few different options particularly with
the availability of Visual Studio code
and visuals a year for Mac which in many
ways are completely different products
from Visual Studio for Windows the so
the question was will there be a
configuration file to make this project
work that I want thanks Brett
let me just turn off my notifications
there will there be a configuration file
to let me fill out all of this
information there will be some of that
there will be different ways of doing it
for different languages right now Visual
Studio has a lot more complexity around
this then something like Visual Studio
code because Visual Studio code
basically came out and said this is the
one way everyone she'll do it this way
and they did that less than five years
ago funeral studio has been around for
twenty thirty years now and people
jumped on at different times and done
things differently
so I'll go through a lot of the
configuration options specifically for
projects as well they're not all as nice
as saying go to this file and edit it to
make it work but the overall aim is that
one day we will get there and I'll also
show a little bit of how we're getting
that direction as well so projects as I
said you'll have some idea in your head
of what a project is Visual Studio has a
different idea or at least very much
more specific idea in general a project
is going to be some collection of files
that come together to be an app or a
website or a task or some set of related
files it's going to include source code
it's going to include data files is
going to include configuration files and
it's going to include some sort of build
steps so the way that you take a file a
project from source code into some
output deployment information everything
that you need to get from the raw set of
source code up to a running website up
to a running service deployed service
result from data analysis a build
executable running on someone else's
machine all of those things get included
in what the project file is in Visual
Studio you mostly see project files in
what's known as solution Explorer I
don't expect you to be following along
at this point by the way there'll be an
opportunity for that I have here two
project files one is the C++ project one
is a Python project again I'll come back
to what these actual projects do later
on but the point right now is different
the projects are going to behave
differently the C++ project has
unsurprisingly C++ files in it it could
also have header files in it and then
there is a whole lot of properties page
typically in Visual Studio if you
right-click anything you're going to see
hundreds of menus I'm sorry that's the
way it is
I'll show you ways that you can work
around that
or ways to improve that later on but in
general if you feel like you need to do
something with something right-clicking
is going to give you all of the options
and more and the most common one that
you'll probably use as properties which
is going to open another page with all
of the options that you need sleep love
slots project is going to have hundreds
of options all to do with how you build
the project because that has to be
included somewhere in Visual Studio it
goes in the project file there's an
actual file on disk it has the extension
vcx proj whole lot of XML that specifies
which files are part of this project
what do we do to them to make them build
where do we put them all of the steps
involved to go from source files to a
working application this also exists for
Python if I right-click and choose
properties on this one you'll see we get
a different sort of window this has some
properties about which file is the most
important python file here typically you
end up with the directory full of python
files one of them you want to start
running when you run the project that
it's going to be your run PI or startup
PI or something along those lines
and that information gets stored in the
project file you'll be using it with
some particular version of Python we put
that in the project file any debug
settings that you may want to run it
with when you start it it needs search
pods
it needs certain arguments when you run
it environment variables to set those go
in the project file so there's a PI proj
file on disk that includes all of that
information this is quite different from
how people who don't use Visual Studio
are going to handle their Python
projects they'll tend to have their own
conventions
they'll have a directory of code and
we'll know which file you're supposed to
run start running or there'll be a
readme that says this is the file you
should run but it's all very manual
Visual Studio with its project files
forces you into that position where you
have to say this is exactly the file to
run and it's consistent across all
projects so we can always do it
automatically and that gets us to the
point where you can have a keyboard
shortcut for it and Visual Studio
doesn't force you to name your main file
something it but it does force you to
tell you which one is the main file so
that it can run it compared to in the
same way if you're going to publish code
somewhere you can tell Visual Studio
published these files don't publish
these ones do this to these files before
publishing you can give it all of the
steps and it just requires you to
provide it in a way that it can follow
so that it can do it for you in much the
same way as a project not using Visual
Studio may say we use ant we use Gradle
we use this tool and follow its
conventions to do the publishing to do
the building to do the transformations
so Visual Studio has all of that it gets
represented in a nice graphical
interface here but that's really all it
is this is essentially your make file
this is your get ignore file this is
publishing profiles all rolled into one
single file to keep it all in one place
now as Visual Studio moves into the
future to make things more flexible to
make things easier for integrating with
other projects people who aren't using
Visual Studio we're actually moving away
from this in a lot of ways so we have
another feature that's now here if I go
to my file open menu I have all the
options for things that I can open here
project is the first one and solution is
like a collection of projects is
essentially all it is if I have related
projects can put them in a solution all
the same things apply which project is
the main one what do I do with various
projects but if you look down you'll see
that open folder is an option
this was also new
in Visual Studio 2017 open folder is
going to take you from being in this
project view of the solution view and
put your interview that's just looking
at your file system this is essentially
like opening the folder in something
like sublime text something like atom
any editors that don't force a project
file on you and just show you whatever
is on disk in a lot of ways this makes
much more sense for developing in Python
where the structure on disk is what
matters and if you move software and in
a project file it's still the structure
on disk that matters when you actually
get to running the code so with this
open folder feature it lets you look at
a directory of code without using a
project file edit it and still configure
a lot of those settings at this point
and this is this is somewhat limited for
python support right now so there are
some things that work there are some
things that don't work but the basics of
it do work if they come and want to
specify and say hey this is this is my
python file that i want you to start
running
I don't have a project file I do have a
project file I'm ignoring it because
it's on disk but I'm ignoring that
project file going to right-click this
and say help debug and launch settings
I'm going to select the default
debugging mode and this is going to open
me up into a JSON file where I can
configure all of these settings so in
essence we've exchanged the project file
that we had before for basically a
hidden JSON file I don't believe this is
called launched okay this is launched
obviously Jason where you can configure
these options and whatever I have setup
in here is going to determine what the
buttons inside Visual Studio do if I
want to start debugging I can specify
what that means in this file I can check
this in if I want it's in a dot vs
folder so it's a little bit hidden but
you can commit it and share it with
other people if you want and you can
basically fill in all the same settings
that you would in the project properties
and they just stored somewhere else
which means that if you're sharing your
code with someone who's not using Visual
Studio that's fine they don't need
Visual Studio they can just look in the
folder and use whatever tools they want
to use they won't necessarily get the
benefits out of this JSON file but they
can go and read it and say oh what am i
visual studio friends using when they
run this code and it's right there in a
file that they can see and they can read
but this is the future right now
particularly for Python projects but
basically for all languages and visual
studio projects the organizational level
that still works best and they have 20
30 years of working with projects to
carry that there's a lot of
functionality that's available to a
project that doesn't yet make sense for
a directory of random files so I'm going
to try and bounce between both of these
as I go through stuff today but they are
certainly both available there and over
time the ability to simply open a folder
of code is going to get better and it's
for a lot of people we hope it's going
to become the default way of working
with soft
and since projects are still the main
way you are going to create new projects
at some point to start a project you
don't have to invent it all from nothing
you get to go to the new project dialog
and select from a whole set of templates
this is going to be a typical starting
point this templates for every language
you have installed here most in my case
were for Python because that's the
language that I've selected with the
most templates there's some basic web
framework templates there as well if you
want to get started with a flask up
django bottle whatever it happens to be
this is the easiest way to get started
all of these are going to be highly
customizable and they don't come with
very much code they're a starting point
for you to start building your app
around and get some of those default
settings set before I move along on to
configuration which i think is going to
be the most interesting exciting part
does anyone have any questions about
projects roughly building stuff I'll get
into some specifics on actually
compiling code in the bit does anyone
want to go a little bit deeper on how
Visual Studio deals with projects I
promise I won't tell the project team
okay
so in my experience people who complain
the visual studio doesn't work the way
they want it are also not familiar with
this menu item tools options is going to
get you into probably the most
complicated dialog you've ever seen this
has a lot of treeview down the side
there's a lot of things that I can
expand and fill up the entire side but
this is the hub of making visual studio
work the way you want it to work if you
really want to annoy a regular visual
studio user the easiest way to do that
is to go into tools options and reset
all their settings it's going to take
someone from a happy Visual Studio user
to a very annoyed one very quickly
question is is there any type of config
file that can help restore their
settings yes you can in fact export your
settings as an XML file and then
re-import it whenever you want you can
easily move that from machine to machine
and import it there's actually a setting
synchronization option which will select
the ones that make sense to synchronize
and then when you log into Visual Studio
on a new machine they'll get loaded in
automatically so there's a number of
ways to work around it again people who
don't get as far as the options dialog
tend not to get as far as exporting
their settings either this is the secret
information that I want to give everyone
so that you do get this far and you do
have a much nicer time using the tool
then the people who don't know that you
can do all of this so people often get
as far as the color theme though so if
you do have Visual Studio running at
this point you've managed to get it
installed and hopefully a I talked for
long enough to let all the installs
finish the color theme is one thing that
people do tend to find so there's four
options now I'm on one of the recent
previews so I have a fourth option it's
been added recently called blue extra
contrast but if I want to change Visual
Studio from a light thing to a dark
theme it's as simple as making that
change hitting okay and in just a second
it's going to go through and redraw the
entire thing in a nice stock thing
personally I prefer the dark theme to
the light theme but it's can be
difficult to see when I'm presenting so
I'll go back to let me jump to the blue
theme
but you can choose this there's also
extensions I'll show you some extensions
in a bit that can let you fully
customize the color theme for the entire
product that will come with their own
collection of themes so you don't even
have to use just the basic quantity that
come with the product you can have
complete freedom in what colors you want
visual studio to be the second part of
coloring stuff comes under this fonts
and colors option
so the theme changes everything across
the entire product fonts and colors work
solely on the editor so when you're in
the text editor for whatever language
you happen to be using there are going
to be items down here in this display
item that you can then change the color
of for example let me let me bring up
some code first
so I have some Python code here you can
see there's a whole lot of blue for
keywords purple for modules there's
green for a class there if I go into the
fonts and colors option I can find start
looking for Python I'll find a group of
Python items and as I scroll through
each of these you'll see the the color
shows up in the preview of what it is
and you can totally just go in and
change whichever one you like so let's
say for some reason that I think it's a
really bad idea to use operators in
Python I can go to that and I can change
the color to red hit OK and now all the
colors in the editor and now red for
that particular thing that I chose to
change this applies to every language in
visual studio this applies to whatever
changes you want to make there's a lot
of freedom here to make things look and
read better for the way you want them to
one of my personal favorites that I like
changing the visible white space you see
all those dots all over the screen
they're really prominent right now and I
don't like that so I like to grab this
fade it out a bit and just make those
that visible whitespace all those dots a
little less prominent that's one of the
common changes that I tend to make
there's a lot of flexibility in the
fonts and colors and of course if you
save your settings and reload them
somewhere else it's going to show up
everywhere else which means I am going
to have red Python operators the rest of
the time so let me fix that
another thing that people often complain
about is keyboard shortcuts visual
sphere has ten million billion trillion
commands in it approximately most of
them have keyboard shortcuts many of
them have multiple keyboard shortcuts
most of them will not tell you what the
keyboard shortcut is every single one
almost every single one is about ten
exceptions you can change the keyboard
shortcut so if there's a command that
you find yourself accidentally hitting
all the time and you don't know what it
is but for some reason you go ah every
time I try and copy something I miss and
I hit ctrl D what does ctrl D do I can
hit ctrl D and it's going to show me
this list of the commands that control D
applies to I can then take these
commands and search for them I can go to
find combo there's the command yet she's
in control D and I can remove that so
now that command doesn't have a keyboard
shortcut I can assign a new on to it
control D assign now it's back virtually
every single command in visual studio
can be customized like this and it's
going to stick it's part of your
settings when you first run it you'll
get a drop down this is do you want
general keyboard settings or c-sharp
keyboard settings or C++ keyboard
settings those can be a good start if
you're familiar with that grouping but
you do have complete freedom to go
through and change any of these that you
want and they are going to show up in
the in the menu items so if I change
something like step over which is
currently f10 I can remove the f10 I can
make it control our control oh you can
do chords you can do pad shortcuts in
this I can assign it hit OK and then
step over is probably not here now there
it is debug step over now says control
our controller
and because this setting is synchronized
every single one of my machines now has
that setting and I'm going to have a
really hard time debugging stuff when I
get back to work in a couple of days but
this is a flexibility in the freedom
that's there in keyboard shortcuts
ironically enough and to be completely
honest I can't explain why the import
and export settings does not let you
import and export settings from PR this
lets you choose where you want to import
and export settings to but when you do
come to the point where you're like I
love my settings I've changed on my
settings they're good they work for me
just above the options is the import and
export settings which will let you have
the choice of exporting importing a
reset or you can choose which ones are
important to export and then that's
setting that you can change in tools
options that doesn't actually let you
import an export is the setting here and
you can change it again so that will let
you have a file it says vs settings it's
an XML file if you want to look at how
the settings are actually stored if you
just want to move it from one machine to
another that is a very good way to get
that to another machine
tubs and windows can also be interesting
depending on what kind of question yes
so the question is are there any
repositories of people shared settings I
am not aware of any I've certainly seen
projects that come with their own set of
settings so you can if you're working on
a particular project you may import
their settings file while working on
that project and that will help with
code formatting being consistent various
options like that many projects make
minimal changes to those it's generally
considered that the default settings are
the good baseline for most languages so
people tend not very too far from that
in part because the extra work of
grabbing a settings file and importing
it is actually more work than adapting
to the settings out of that there are a
few special cases I'll show you one a
little bit that is very interesting but
essentially the default settings tend to
get used as a good baseline and then
people make minimal changes on top of
that so this doesn't windows option
depending on how you like your image
your windows to work this is a really
big thing should be working a lot within
Visual Studio you have editor windows
and tool windows they are fundamentally
different in ways that don't really
matter a huge amount to most people
broadly editor windows like the big one
that has the text in it get tabbed
across the top tool windows get docked
around the side so you can see the art
history window over there is a tool
window it's docked to the side they
close Visual Studio and open it again
it'll come back the editor windows fit
in the middle if I close Visual Studio
it's going to say do you want to save
and if I say no then I'll close and I'll
open again it'll be gone so you can
think of it editor window is a document
tool window is not this becomes relevant
because the options are different for
each one
you can do a variety of things with
pinned documents if you're used to
pinning inside of a web browser so you
can pin a document that's going to keep
it always open always in a particular
position if you have 100 documents open
this is really really handy if you're
working on one main document jumping
around a whole lot of others and there's
an option in there to put it on a
separate road which can keep it even
more obvious once it's pinned by really
separating it from the other windows the
one that I find myself changing most
often is this preview tab visual studio
has a feature where if you're bouncing
around files you're like going to
definition over and over again or you're
jumping into a file temporarily it will
open the file temporarily in what's
called the preview tab and then when
you're done it's just going to go away
you can disable that from here I
personally disabled this all the time
apart from this machine right now
apparently but now it's disabled
directories is a very important thing
that people always like to change and I
recommend it under the projects and
solutions section and again I strongly
recommend if you want to make visual
studio work for you go through each one
of these see what you can change see
what it does once you know the option is
there it's relatively easy to find out
what it does a lot of the time you
simply won't know the options even
available this locations for projects
and solutions I strongly recommend
changing it's going to come with some
interesting defaults particularly the
first one which is whenever you make a
new project where do we put the files by
default it's going to go somewhere in
your Documents folder most of the time
we want it to go somewhere more useful
or at least somewhere that doesn't start
with you know a hundred characters about
260 character limit at the start of the
path so this is where you can change
that every single project that I create
is going to default to see projects
instead of going somewhere deeper this
is a really handy one to be able to
change and if you're working with
net-net core visual visual c++ there
options here for it as well text editor
is likely to be the section where you
spend the most of your time certainly is
for me this is where you get specific
control over specific languages in the
editor there's a section for all
languages this is really convenient for
things like do you want tabs or spaces
as you can see I have the correct answer
you can also choose to keep tabs and use
tabs in editors certain languages you
can specify the tab size the indent size
they're currently blank because they're
different per language but if you do
just want to set every single language
all at once this is the tab to do that
in you'll also get options for
automatically listing code suggestions
as you're typing can be controlled from
here for all languages virtual space
which I'm going to turn on because which
was base is an interesting one line
numbers URLs there's a handful of
options here that you may want to adjust
scroll bar as well far more options for
a scroll bar than you ever thought could
have existed but there's plenty of
things to change here and in fact I'm
going to turn on map mode because this
is one of my favorite things about the
scroll bar and they'll leave the tooltip
on and let me show you what that does oh
look at my scroll bar now rather than
being a simple jump up and down narrow
bar I can see a preview of my code I can
actually see more of a preview as I
hover over it jump to wherever I want if
you happen to have a touchscreen this is
infinitely more usable than a regular
scroll bar
and as you gunned down into various
languages you'll get more options so
jump into Python the first couple of
pages are the same so the scroll bar
options are similar tabs are similar in
this case it is specific to the language
so if I change the option here it's not
going to affect any other language it's
simply going to adjust if I'm working on
Python code then I'll insert spaces it's
going to insert four at a time I can
change that to be some other number for
those who are going to the pop quiz I'm
sure this will come up but this is
that's actually the correct value for a
tab size in Python is eight because a
little bit of Python trivia just a fun
every tab in python counts as eight
spaces I don't know why but it does so
if you hit tab it's going to count as a
if you hit tab and you put eight spaces
below it it counts with the same thing
so that's arguably the right tab size of
Python is eight spaces which I'm not
going to use further down we have this
Advanced tab this didn't show up for all
languages because it's different for
each language
so there's Python specific options in
here that only apply to the Python code
things that you may want to change since
we're probably most interested in this
slide let me spend a little bit more
time on it this first option member
completion displays intersection of
members we're in visual studio if you're
familiar with visual studio you know as
soon as you start typing and you hit dot
it's going to show you a list of
everything that might come next threat
for Python because a variable is not one
fixed type it could be it could be a
string or a list or a number or whatever
in that value at that time we've got a
choice of what to show you it might be
legitimately three different types in
that case you only want to see members
that are going to be on all three of
those types otherwise you might use
something that is going to be an error
checking that box is going to show you
that
let me show you a quick sample of that
X in this case could be three things in
Lystra strength we can do flow analysis
by reading it we know exactly what it's
going to be right because we've
overwritten it but imagine if we put
this in you know if random is greater
than 0.5 then suddenly we don't know
which one it's going to be so the
members of X that we may want to use are
going to vary in fact those are all the
special ones let's not use the special
one
okay okay let me take that out so now
it's just going to be an enter a float
two different types of numbers we don't
actually know which one it might be at
this point in our code so we only want
the options that are definitely
available for both if I take out the
fact that it might be a float
oh it's Python 3:6 isn't it oh there we
go okay hmm we get more options that are
just for an end but as soon as we throw
in or it could be a float that option
intersect is only going to show us the
things that both of those types could be
which does mean that if it could be two
incompatible types you'll very quickly
get to the point where there's no types
available anymore because you have
completely incompatible values showing
up in that if I disable this option
which is the default instead of
excluding things that are not on both
we're going to highlight which one they
belong to this particular setting only
applies to Python code it's it's a
feature of the Python editor to be able
to say oh this could be an integer or a
float so we'll tell you which ones are
only unint which ones are only on float
the ones that show up everywhere don't
get any specifier you can safely use
conjugate on this value whether it's an
injury fluid and it's going to be just
fine going down filter list that list
that pops up if I disable this as I type
it's going to jump to the best option
but it's not actually going to remove
anything from the list and automatically
sure just means that as I start typing
your name it's going to pop up with the
list straightaway if I turn this off
it's only going to pop up if I press dot
fire like if I'm doing something that
definitely has a list of things to show
this was one of our most requested
features a couple of years back it's
like I start typing I just want the
suggestions to come just give me give me
the suggestions let me take them
this list of characters you probably
never have to change but if for some
reason you want to change it then it's
here what this means is that if you type
any of these characters we're going to
say oh whatever selected is the best
selection and you want it and so it will
keep going so you'll see that
parentheses are in here
at the start what that means is that if
I type if I have ABS selected but I've
only typed eight and now I type one of
those characters it commits it it
finishes off the completion if you don't
like that then I can take the
parentheses out of here
do the same thing and now instead of
completing it it doesn't add anything
else at all so it's exactly what I type
depending on what editor what background
you've come from that may be how you
prefer it to work the next two options
apply to how enter does that as well
if you partway through something and you
hit enter and it's selected it's going
to finish it off for you if you type the
whole thing and it's selected and you
hit enter the next option determines
whether you go to the next line or not
which is not the default but again some
people really like this option so it's
there to be able to do it these last
three options are fairly miscellaneous
you can't see in this demo file but if I
open another one I'll be able to show
you the outlining mode so you'll see
here we have these blocks of code that I
can collapse and hide this is outlining
mode that option that said enter
outlining mode and files open is a very
weirdly named option it basically means
do you get those collapsible blocks or
not so you leave it ticked if you go
back in history you'll find that at one
point every language had this option
with the same name and that's how we
ended up with this option with the same
name but that's essentially all it means
page removes repple prompts is what
probably one of my favorite features
right now if you run some code in Python
let me just open up a normal Python
prompt and I can do you know a few bits
of Python code now if I want to take
this and paste it into Visual Studio I
can select it and I've got these prompts
in it so when I paste it it's going to
have prompts but it's not which means
it's not valid Python code because it
has all these extra angle brackets with
that option that says remove wrapper
prompts when I paste it they actually go
away if you really wanted them then you
can go back to undo and you'll see at
the top undo item is remove ripple
prompts that will bring
and if you under one more time then the
whole fingers away so that's that's
there by default but if you don't want
to doing that then turn the option off
and when you paste they'll just stealer
the final option uses a bit more deeper
analysis so it's really easy in Python
code to say oh you have class my class
let me change the color of my class to
show that it's a class it's a bit more
work to go through the rest of the file
and say every way you used my class it's
still a class let's color it like a
class it's even more work to say oh you
assigned my class to a different name
and then imported it into another file
and now 17 files away it's still a class
and figure out that it's still a class
even jumping through all those hoops
that's what this option does if you have
this enabled we'll try and figure that
out and make it look like a class
everywhere the quick demo of that my
class you'll see in a second it will
turn the light green color assuming that
everything is falling apart on me ah no
it won't because I turn the option off
we actually have two levels on this
option only one of them is visible which
is if we know it's a class we'll call it
a class everywhere if you turn that
option off we won't do that we'll do
basic syntax highlighting there's a
minor performance improvement there we
largely put the option in so that people
had the ability to say oh I need that
extra performance on my machine let me
turn that feature off but then we do do
things like oh you reassigned it we know
that MC is going to be a class it's
definitely a class because you just
assigned the class to it and flow the
color through everywhere when things are
not falling asleep on E
and finally there's formatting options
we have code formatting in Python it's
fairly simplistic we try to be really
really careful not to change the
behavior of your code by automatically
formatting it and changing weight space
around so compared to some other
languages auto format where the weight
spaces are relevant and it's okay for
the formatter to throw it out and you
know invent new weight space for you we
try not to do that in Python so it's
compared to if you used to c-sharp sort
of formatting you might find this
disappointing because we're not going to
reinvent everything for you it's too
risky
we don't want to break your code we
don't break your code so much that we'd
rather not reformat your code too hard
either so but the options are there and
you can certainly get formatting if I
keep going down you'll see the same
thing exists or they can jump to the
advanced paint our has its own set of
Advanced Options each other language has
its own set of Advanced Options
formatting options things that you might
want to change everything from commit on
Enter key which I change from the
default because I like hitting answers
to complete what I'm typing if you're
coming from an art studio background
where that isn't how it works then you
probably want to leave this off because
then it's going to feel like it's
behaving the same way so there's a lot
of ability in here to change these
settings to make it feel the way you
want it to feel
and when you find something that you
need changed something new and fancy or
you know complete modification Visual
Studio is highly extensible ridiculously
extensible in fact if you go back to
tools instead of going into options
we're going to go to extensions and
updates'
which for me is the second menu item I
believe the first one is new in this
preview so it may be the first menu item
if you're on the slightly earlier update
we have here the visual studio
marketplace this is full of the most
popular extensions for visual studio the
majority of which are completely free
and you can just download and install
them into visual studio very easily
these will do basically anything you can
think of the ones I really want to draw
your attention to I'm going to call out
indent guides you might recognize the
name of the creator
this is one of mine so you know
shameless self-promotion but what this
extension does is adds the vertical
lines that you might have noticed in the
background while I was typing right
there that show you when things are
lining up this is really common in a lot
of editors Visual Studio doesn't have it
but you can add it through this
extension every indentation it's going
to draw a line linking everything up so
you can see the blocks that come
together when you have the cursor inside
a certain block it will highlight the
line make it obvious where you are so
this extension if you get free to
install I don't get paid for this will
provide that functionality
the other one that I suspect a lot of
people will like is called vs vim if you
like vim keybinding or vim navigation
behavior in the editor this extension
will provide it this gives you the
ability to jump between navigation mode
and editing mode inside the vs editor I
don't have it turned on right now so I
can't demonstrate it I would embarrass
myself if I tried to demonstrate it to
be honest and I didn't find anyone
willing to get up and demonstrate it
right now so I suggest you go if you are
in Visual Studio or you have access to
it and want to try try it out without
getting too far away from how you use
vim this is certainly worth a go this is
written by a member of the team that
works on the C sharp integration it's
one of the best quality extensions out
there because the ones written by visual
studio team members tend to be good
quality extensions so don't worry about
it breaking your machine completely it's
going to be really handy for that and
I've actually been suggested that this
relative line numbers can also be very
helpful if that's what you used to
seeing line numbers relative to the
current position or to wherever you set
it today so
so that's roughly the configuration
availability in Visual Studio
it's fairly huge everything that you do
will synchronize between machines
extensions will automatically install on
new machines if you've set that up to
synchronize so it's very easy to
transfer settings from machine to
machine can all be exported imported and
you can do a lot to make Visual Studio
look and feel the way you want for one
thing that I missed which is this tools
customized option if you go into this
you end up in honestly one of the least
easy-to-use customization dialogues
you've ever seen but it provides you
with the full ability to modify every
single menu every single toolbar every
single context menu inside Visual Studio
so I have a whole lot of menus shown in
this list which are appearing across the
top here if I want to remove one of
these let's say I don't want the team
menu I can delete that team menu just
disappeared from up top if I want to get
rid of the help menu I can delete the
help menu in the help menus going from
up top if I want to modify that file new
these are the options that show up under
file new and I can add the command from
basically anywhere so now I can add
watch under the file new menu this is
you know if you're really really
committed to making Visual Studio look
and feel the way you want it to this you
might spend months working through this
dialog to make it happen but you can
customize everything keyboard shortcuts
menu layout menu location it's all there
it's all available to do that and there
is one extension that's gone above and
beyond to make it even easier because if
you've come from a studio and you're
using the our tooling and you just want
it to look like a studio then you can go
to our tools and select the start of
science settings option
which I'm not going to proceed with
because it's going to spoil the rest of
my day right now but if you jump through
this it's going to modify all of these
settings for you and give you visual
studio that looks like a studio matching
shortcuts matching window layout similar
toolbars it is the total conversion for
visual studio that will get you into an
environment you're used to if that
environment is our studio we don't
currently have anything similar for
other ideas but again this is something
that you can go through and set up
yourself export and say hey here are the
visual studio settings to be like
pycharm here the visual studio settings
to be like pydev
for the visual studio settings to be
like whatever other idea you like and
those can then be imported by anyone the
the our studio ones if you're using the
our tools are already built in let's
customization I'm about to move onto
some Python and our specific stuff does
anyone want to ask any more sort of
broad visual studio questions before I
do that yeah oh yeah no absolutely so
the question is is there any management
for parentheses in most languages I
believe you're going to get Auto clothes
for starters so every time I add an open
one it's going to add a closed one and
we'll do that for whatever shape we want
it should be it should be so the
functionality is part of Visual Studio
its opt-in per language from the
language implementer point of view so
the people responsible for the language
support have got to say I want to enable
this I want to use it and then it's
really simple for them to do that but if
they haven't done it then it's not
necessarily going to be available
certainly c-sharp C++ Python I believe
are all do this already
f-sharp certainly does all the
JavaScript and similar languages are
going to do it as well so the vast
majority certainly do
and as you can see it's not very bright
but as I select one it it's highlighted
slightly the other one highlights again
if I want that to be more obvious than
it's a matter of what's go to fonts and
colors and if I find race matching here
is the background color for brace
matching I can change that to red and
that didn't actually work in Python oh
we have a bug on that yeah
our team does not have a bug on that so
because I changed the background color
for race matching to red it's now really
obvious where they match up so yeah that
should come as standard for every
language and if not fine mate you can
report an issue reporting an issue in
VIN studio 2017 we love it when people
do this by the way this is the send
feedback button up here that goes to
report a problem if you hit a problem or
something doesn't work or you can't
figure out how to do something report it
through this even if it's just that you
can't figure out how to do something
from the point of view of the people who
say visual studio should be really
usable that's a problem so we want you
to tell us that this was too hard to
figure out we'll help you figure it out
you end up with a link on a forum Stack
Overflow style where we'll eventually
give you the solution so you will get
help but this report a problem is a
great way to do that so if someone
hasn't often want to report a problem
and say I changed the brace matching
color for Python and it didn't work then
I will get a bug filed against me until
I go and fix that yes
customers as in you mean a subset of the
total settings yes so so when you do go
to import export settings you can choose
exactly which ones you want to be
exporting so from here you know I would
start by doing that and you'll find
under options text editor yeah there so
there is some functionality in the
c-sharp support for using I it
absolutely is
I believe there's extensions available
for that the c-sharp and VB and f-sharp
editors have the ability to detect I
forget exactly what it's called but it's
like a standard format of saying here is
the text formatting for this project and
they're able to detect that file in a
directory and say okay we'll update the
settings to match that project if you
want to do multiple settings the way
you're suggesting the standard way in
Visual Studio would be to export
multiple times to different files and
then import those files so it's not
quite as simple as a drop-down in the
product but it's certainly going to
behave that way because when you learn
the export a selection of settings when
you import those settings it's only
going to update those settings as well
so you can export C shut to different
files with just a c-sharp settings or
just the Python settings just the are
settings then choose which one you want
to import and it's only going to update
those settings so it's a couple of extra
steps as I say I believe there's
extensions that will make that easier I
don't personally use any of those so I
can't recommend yeah but that's yeah
that's a great question I'm sure it's
being I'm sure it's been considered and
worked on as a feature before I don't
know if it's in progress are coming soon
at this point but I'm sure there's an
extension that can help with that and as
I say there's some products stuff to
help out yes yeah so per instance
settings like in Visual Studio code
don't currently exist in Visual Studio
simply because the the instance nurse of
Visual Studio doesn't really exist at
this point the best you can get as far
as two separate instances is having
visual studio and Visual Studio preview
which is going to have extra updates in
it that have not yet been released and
stable to everyone those are those are
separate instances so you can have
totally different settings between
preview and the the main visual studio
release because they are separate it is
technically possible to have as many
instances as you like but it has not
been justified as worth the confusion
that it's likely to cause to enable that
right now so but I would not be at all
surprised to see Visual Studio get to
the same sort of per project settings
with Visual Studio code users any other
questions before we move on yes
am I going to talk about the bugging
Python very briefly the short answer to
debugging Python is yes you can and if
you use the debugging anything else in
Visual Studio it's much the same if
you're not used to debugging in Visual
Studio then I cannot cover visual
Studios debugging functionality in 2
hours because it is probably the most
complete blogger on the market at the
moment so suffice to say that yes you
can
I'll demonstrate very briefly some of
the base functionality but I'm not going
to go in-depth into that right now
there's plenty of material online that
applies to most languages in Visual
Studio okay sorry
let me close all of that
I just realized that I missed a very
important topic so let me cover that
quickly who uses get who knew that you
could use get from within Visual Studio
cool who knows how to use get that's a
lot fewer hands up than before who knows
how to use get from within Visual Studio
honestly I've been learning get very
slowly for a long time
but when I try to use it from Visual
Studio I got it straight away it's
certainly been one of the most intuitive
ways of dealing with kids that I've ever
come across and so I'm quite happy to
recommend it let's quickly do that if
you are following along this is
something that you can join in with this
will make sure that you've got all the
sample code that I've been showing and
the stuff I'm about to go into an a bit
more depth the team Explorer window is
the home of collaboration in Visual
Studio you can get to it through view
team Explorer you can get to it through
the team menu that I deleted in an
earlier demo but view team Explorer is a
good way to get into it you see a couple
of options there and all we really want
to start with is click on manage
connections which is the non obvious
part of how to do this and that's going
to get you to a page that has some
options this has some git repositories
I've already cloned before but we're
going to clone a new one you probably
don't have any showing up here
but because git is basically the number
one version control system inside Visual
Studio these days it's the main one that
you'll be pushed towards using we've
gone all in in case you haven't been
keeping up basically every single big
project at Microsoft is now using git
which includes Windows which includes
Visual Studio basically every big
project that's going on is all running
out of git and largely get running on
visual studio comm so you can actually
sign up and be using the same get system
that is capable of handling Windows
which I probably don't have to tell you
is a very very very big project the
Visual Studio repository is a number of
gigabytes large for a single you know
working directory and the history is
even more significant so if you do work
on projects that are that big and have a
need for get beyond what github is
capable of then visual studio team
services which is visual studio comm you
can get free accounts there is certainly
going to be capable of handling it but
the repository that we're cloning right
now is from github so if you get into
the team Explorer page connect manage
connection buttons and we're going to
clone a repository and the repository is
coming from my personal account
Zuba 0ba slash PI data example which
I'll leave up on the screen long enough
you can see a few people entering it in
that's right github comm slash Zubov 0b
a / pi data example or one word
capitalisation shouldn't matter
and then I'm just going to hit clone on
that if we all hit clone at exactly the
same time github is probably not going
to notice but I'm sure the Wi-Fi here
will notice and it might not work as
well then again it's not a huge
repository on three everyone ready
and of course the demo Wi-Fi is doing
exactly what was expected and we're not
getting that so whether you've cleaned
it already zero be a slash pay data
example there we go
not because it's a public repository on
github you'll be able to clone it down
now if you try and push to this then
you're going to be prompted for
authentication and because you don't
have it you're not going to be able to
push anything to my repository you won't
be able to push anything to it today but
if you clone your own repository if you
want to fork this from github and then
clone your own one you can feel free to
do that and then when you push it will
prompt for github credentials that's
integrated into Visual Studio so it will
go oh this is on github let me pop up
the github login let me do the
two-factor authentication if you've got
that enabled and let's you be pushing
directly to github from within Visual
Studio it's going to remember your
sign-in information so eventually it's
going to expire and we'll get you to
enter it in again but for a while
it's going to remember who you are yes
yes so if you want to add an existing
repository rather than going to clone
you can go to add and if you know the
full part you can enter it in or you can
hit the dot start browsing and select
the repository that way you'll end up in
the same situation as I'm in here once
you have the repository you can double
click on it you get to see some more
information now visual studio is going
to detect any solution files that are in
there so you'll see there's two
solutions python extension module and a
shiny movies solution those are because
I check those into the repository so
let's just found those if you do pull a
project that's based in Visual Studio
you'll get some extra nicety here you
can double click on these or you can hit
show folder view that's going to jump
into the open folder view I showed you
before I'm going to click on this in a
sec but before we get there there are
branches view which is maybe new to
maybe surprising I keep finding people
that have never seen like a
visualization of branches and get before
and some people have and you know
there's a variety out there but a lot of
people are so used to the command line
that's seeing it visually represented in
any form can be a very new experience
the branches page is where you can you
can make new branches you get the
ability to clone new clone pool fetch
push everything that's involved you can
rebate some other branches merge from
other branches view history is probably
the most valuable one I don't have a lot
of history in this repository but this
is going to be a visual representation
that's going to show everywhere that was
merged back and forth any rebasing is
going to show up as rebasing it's
basically the visual history and I can
go back to any of these and say hey give
me what happened here
commit details see more details see what
was changed do diffs on each of the
files to see the change it's basically
there's very few needs to in most cases
to jump out of visual studios to deal
with git
which makes me very happy and of course
if you do want to jump out to a visual
studio to use git it's just a thin layer
on top of the command line tool so
anything you're doing here is
essentially running the command line
tool in the background you can do
exactly the same things from the command
line with git and it will update in
Visual Studio as well
so if I go and create a new branch it's
going to show up in Visual Studio
automatically and I can switch to it
Visual Studio knows when I've switched
to it it knows when I've committed from
the command line so you don't have to
break your old flow completely but you
do have the ability to choose whether
you're in visual studios get a command
line get but they are the same one they
do align nicely so if I open the show
folder view this is going to give me the
view that we saw earlier this is my
directory of code that just has a
handful of files in it and I'm going to
start with some of the interactive
scripts hit this note here about
solutions and folders this toolbar
button here basically brings you back to
that list we saw before so if you have
an actual visual studio project in there
which we do and I'll show in a sec that
drop down will just let you choose it to
open it and switch between this view of
just all the files and one of the
particular projects right now I'm just
going to pull up an example script which
is just one of my matplotlib demos I
pointed out before the collapsible
blocks this is part of the workflow for
Python individual studio that we that
just from chatting with people seems to
be something that is added value on top
of a common interactive workflow so if I
open that if I have my interactive
window open let me stick that there
then if I'm working from the command
line or working in I pass and less so a
drip in a notebook but if I'm working
locally in my tools then I may have the
the ipython show handy be running code
in that and wanting to see the results
and somehow keeping it at the same time
so I've got a record of what I did
obviously a dip in a notebook makes this
really easy really nice sometimes I'm
not working in one of those if I'm
working from Visual Studio then we have
this kind of workflow this collapsible
block gives me a really easy way to say
hey take this entire block the shortcut
I'm using is ctrl enter and that's just
going to send the whole thing over here
so that just executed that entire block
and don't move the cursor to the next
block so I can keep doing that and be
seeing results in this interactive
window and visual studio so it gives me
essentially a scratch pad if you like
somewhere I can work on my code edit it
and quickly run a big chunk of it in an
interactive window see whatever outputs
I get displayed as a plot which is
resizable if I want go back and edit
this block so I can come back over here
and make a little change if I want
quickly run it again and see new result
so there's a few pieces here that are
interesting in a few I don't to say
traps but a few things that aren't
necessarily obvious that you've got to
set up to make this work the first thing
is I need to I need this to be running
against a particular version of Python I
have the Python environments window open
here this is available under view other
windows Python environments as a Python
developer if you have multiple versions
of Python installed which if you're on
Windows you probably do because everyone
wants you know Python 36 for fun
Python - 7 for work anaconda for work
then you're going to have multiple
copies installed and you need to be able
to review them manage them use them so
this is a list of everything that's been
detected on my machine you'll see that I
don't have python two-seven on there for
work because i work
Microsoft and if you'd also like to work
somewhere where you don't have to use
Python to seven for work you know feel
free to apply but I do have anaconda
installed and I've got a couple of
versions of Python 3 Python 35 and 36
there's a help link here if I want help
finding more environments that's just
going to jump to one of our
documentation pages we'll give you some
pins to tell you where to look but
really the top recommendation now is
when you're installing Visual Studio
just leave that anaconda box ticked
because that's what we recommend and
then we'll do the job of making sure
that you've got the most up-to-date
version on your machine and if you do
have another one somewhere that we
didn't detect we you can add a custom
one you can configure your own
environment name it whatever you want
if you select the path where it's
installed and then hit Auto detect we'll
try and figure out the rest and then you
can apply and you've got your own copy
of Python wherever that happens to be we
know people have users with Maya the
views it with blender you can use it
with ironpython you can use it from pi
PI Jason to add those in the ones that
can't automatically be detected by the
visual studio
yes just about just about to get to that
so you'll notice that when I was sending
code from the editor to the interactive
window I just hit ctrl enter I didn't
tell it where to send it I didn't tell
it which environment it should use
whether it should use anaconda Python 3
Python 2 whatever in this case it's
going to default to the one that's the
default so you'll notice in this list
that anaconda is bolded it's got a much
heavier font name than that and this top
message here says this is the default
environment for new projects so this is
configurable if I change to another one
I can make this the default environment
it says new projects that's accurate
it's also the default environment for a
handful of other things if I just have a
Python file open it's going to assume
that I want it to run against anaconda
so if I come into this random file right
click and say start without debugging
it's going to start running it with
anaconda in this case nothing happens
because it's not designed for running as
a script but that's it's going to run
with the default environment working
down this list you'll see there's a link
to the distributor's website this is
just to help you get to the right place
for help in this case it'll take you to
an issue tracker for anaconda so if you
do happen to hit a problem they're the
people that can help you best the open
interactive window button is going to
jump to this window we also have it up
here as a shortcut so if you want to
jump to anyone
really quick you can just click on it
now I have a Python 3 6 interactive
window without having to jump into the
more detailed list
now there isn't very interesting helpful
checkbox here called use ipython
interactive mode you'll notice that the
very first thing that happened in the
Anaconda interactive window right up at
the top is we had this big display oh
we're in ipython and five-30 that's
because I've enabled this ipython
interactive mode what that means is that
when you've enabled that and you've got
a Python installed and numpy and pandas
map load live and everything will give
you all you get all of the magic
commands you get all of the question
mark for help
any plots that you produce are going to
appear in line and be resizable and it
behaves like being in the I pipe and
interactive prompt which just saves you
from having to jump out and and change
for another window for that it's
obviously if if you've only ever used
the Drupada notebook it's not quite at
that level it's more like the command
line interacting into i-pass then still
very powerful still very helpful it's
just not the web browser view we have
plans and thoughts about how to
integrate that and make that really
useful from visual studio but they're
not there yet
if you disable this you'll see that it's
disabled for Python 36 I'm just going to
get a regular prompt which doesn't do
question marks it says what is this or
is if I do that from
well it doesn't know what this is if I
do it from here it's going to display
hope because I'm in ipython mode so
that's the difference there
I Python mode is what you need to be
able to get the inline plots and so
that's how that works
the other thing that I really want you
to know about because this can really
help if you're spending a lot of time in
Interactive windows is this Explorer
interactive scripts button if I click on
this it's going to open up a directory
you can see where this is in My
Documents folder so this will be in your
Documents folder as well when you open
it up what this is is a collection of
code and if I open the readme it will
explain more but we won't read that now
it's a collection of Python files and
every time I open this particular
interactive window it's going to run
them all so what this means is that if
you have some helpful func helper
functions that you run every time before
you start doing any interactive coding
if there's certain things you want to
import that you need certain settings
you want to change you can put them in
their own file here and they'll get run
on startup so the examples that I have
which if you've cloned it are all under
the Python interactive window folder I
have that's
as a starting point I'm going to change
one of the default parameters of math
lib because when I generate my figures I
want them to be 300 dpi not 72 or
whatever the default is so I have this
little bit of code when I put that in
the interactive scripts folder every
time I open that interactive window it
runs this and changes the default dpi if
I go back to this window let me start a
new one of these
you'll see that I have this empty cars
variable if you're familiar with our you
know that empty cars is built in two are
essentially you have a data set that's
there that has cars and weights and
miles per gallon and all of this stuff
and in Python you don't get that unless
you have added a script that contains
the empty cars data set and then every
time you open the interactive window you
that script gets run and it creates the
data set for you so now in my anaconda
interactive I have NT cars just there by
default and if I decide to take that and
start plotting it
so if I plot the weight of the car
against the miles per gallon of the car
you'll see I get this nice plot that
doesn't look like map lot lives normal
style and that's because one of the
scripts that I have in there is one that
changes the default sail to look like
ggplot so just by putting a few simple
scripts into this directory here
specifically anaconda every time I open
the interactive it gets customized to be
the way that I want it to be so it comes
preset up however I want it to be set up
you don't get into this place where it's
like start a new one run this command
run this command oh I reset it now I've
got to go through and do them all again
up up enter up enter and you can save
them in standard files so that they're
there and they don't actually have to do
anything straightaway they can define a
function they can import a module they
will be run at startup but it's like
them so they can define a class they can
import things they can delete things
whatever it is you want to do you get to
configure the interactive window before
you actually get started and since we
had the question earlier about other
repositories of settings out there other
repositories of script files like this
well not yet but if you'd like to start
any let me know will happily promote
them and encourage people to go and get
helpful files like that the one that you
cloned earlier is the first repository
with some of these files in it so if you
would like to send even some poor
requests against that repository and say
oh here's some of my interactive Windows
startup scripts can you add them into
there I'd like to share them with other
people feel free I'll happily merge them
in or if you'd like to start a
repository and say hey here are some
scripts maybe copy them into your folder
because they'll be helpful for you then
feel free
so if I jump back to this Python
environments window there's a drop down
here it says overview in fact let me
show you something that I really and a
little bit proud of if I take this
window and resize it wide I get a
totally different layout because it
makes a bit more sense this way when
you've got the width so I still have my
list of environments down the side like
I did before and there's sections here
so there's an overview section as
packages and intellisense if I jump into
the packages section it's going to show
me everything that's installed in that
environment and let me install more
things let me update so it's working
right now and it's going to come back
and say oh you should update all of
these packages because they're not up to
date
assuming that conference Wi-Fi works out
for us
I'll go to a shorter list this uses PIP
currently some of that future work is
planning to integrate Condor into this
so if you are using anaconda then this
list will use Condor to install packages
and update them right now it's all based
around PIP so if you come to this and
start searching for a package it's going
to search pipe I just the standard
repository it's going to come back with
suggestions for packages you might want
to install it'll tell you what version
they're at and then it's just going to
go off and use pip to install it this
shows up for virtual environments full
environments if you've installed for an
administrator then we're going to pop up
I don't think I've installed that for an
administrator nope if you've installed
for an administrator I have an installed
that for an administrator either to that
demo file if you've installed for an
administrator and you're trying to
install something we're going to pop up
a prompt and make you all of a because
people keep running into trouble with
that the default install through visuals
here is as an administrator so when you
install anaconda when you install python
it's going to be locked down and secured
to avoid people changing it so we want
to make sure that you're an
administrator to install anything but
will pop up the prompt if you need it
we'll show search results for packages a
little bit of description here to
install and once you've installed a
package then there's one extra step and
this extra step is there intellisense
engine Python is a very difficult
language to do code suggestions for very
difficult language to do full type
analysis type in to help a huge amount
when they're there and when they're not
there as they haven't been for most of
pythons existence to figure out the type
of a variable at any point is actually a
really really difficult problem
so we cheat a little bit and do a whole
lot of pre-emptive work and save it as a
result particularly for the standard
library and any packages you've got
installed so this is a very long list of
all the things that we see are installed
in anaconda and we've gone through all
of these and we've done our preemptive
analysis and we've saved the results
what this means is that when you install
a package we need to go and do some of
that again so there's going to be a bit
of work to refresh and make sure that
it's up to date if you look at platinum
36 right just some sort a whole lot of
packages you'll see that these are not
up to date there's a handful that we're
missing at the moment you won't get
intellisense on these because we don't
have it hit refresh DB it's going to
start working might take a couple of
minutes this is part of the process but
if this hasn't been done then you can be
in the editor and you'll get squiggles
all over the place you'll get you'll hit
dot and you'll see nothing you'll take
import and you'll see nothing this is a
necessary step right now we have plans
to get rid of it and make it so you
don't need to do this so it's more
transparent but right now this is a
necessary step so if you're using the
Python support and wondering why we're
not giving any help at all it's worth
jumping into the Python environments
window and see whether you need to
update some of the intellisense and
finally since people are asking about it
debugging in Python
so visual studio supports breakpoints in
the editor so I just set a breakpoint
there on that line because I don't
actually have this in a project why it's
not in a project the support for running
stuff outside of a project is basic for
yeah
but I can right-click in any file and
select start with debugging this will
use my default environments in this case
anaconda and it's just going to start
debugging the program when we get up to
the language that breakpoint it's going
to stop and let me inspect the rest of
the program if you use the bugging in
any IDE before this is not going to be
incredibly surprising to you but the
support that we have in Visual Studio is
some of the most powerful debugging
support that's out there and we in fact
have one of the strongest features which
I'll show you in a sec once we hit the
breakpoint here let me jump to that and
I will show you one of the coolest
things that's out there that only Visual
Studio has
this might actually be struggling
because of the database refresh there we
go
so when debugging hits this plane here
you'll see a yellow arrow show up at
that line from there I can be steppin
line by line through I can hover over
variables to see what their current
values are I can see in the locals
window all of the local variables that I
have we have a debug interactive window
if i select python debug interactive
this one is under debug windows because
we're debugging rather than a few
windows but in this window i have the
ability to interact more like a python
programs and more like i'm actually
broken out the state in the python
program and interacting with it with
python code it doesn't have all of the
fancy ipython stuff in it but it does
have all of the basic python
functionality that you may expect
now the thing that I want to jump to is
this patent extension module dot SLN so
rather than being in the folder view now
I'm going to open a particular project
the hope is that one day you won't need
to do this we'll be able to have it set
up so that we can go oh you've got a
Python project an extension module set
off and we can detect that and it all
just works right now it works best Oh
what this is what you will see if you
have not installed well that didn't
happen half an hour ago
let's try that again
so that dialogue which you saw before is
when you don't have the right components
installed I can't explain why it just
popped up then but we're in now and I
have not that file the two projects that
I started the session with a Python
project and it's a + + project one of
the strongest points that Visual Studio
has over most other ideas is the ability
to have multiple languages going on at
the same time so you don't need to have
a separate IDE for Python that's
separate from your C++ one you can have
them both going together at the same
time so in this C code which as I said
before you've you've now cloned it you
can work through at your own pace but
this is a basic extension module for
Python so rather than implementing a
Python module in Python I've implemented
it in C which should give me a
significant speed up for the operation
that it's doing this was being created
from one of our templates so we have a
C++ template that will create a Python
extension module and just let you fill
in the gaps we'll do most of the
boilerplate stuff that looks like this
will let you write your function that
looks more like this and you know it
suspect too many people the boilerplate
looks easier to write and that's
probably true this is not this is into
very advanced territory for most Python
developers but the fact that we can have
it in the same IDE that our Python code
is in and our Python version of the same
code makes it much simpler to work on
this I can then have a reference so a
reference lets you associate a project
with another project so in this case my
module tests project which has the very
slow Python version of this function is
referencing the super fast code version
of the same function which is the one
implemented and see by having that
reference like when I now hit build in
Visual Studio it's going to build both
the projects and it's going to make sure
that it builds the referenced one first
before it gods the one that references
it that doesn't have to build the Python
project right now but if you end up with
a long chain of project references to
important to build them in the right
order what it does do for Python though
is it updates the search path
automatically so because I have that
reference there it knows where to find
the built extension module which means
when I hit f5 it's going to build the
extension module and then run Python and
I can import and use it and I can
actually get intellisense on it so
you'll see that my import of superfast
code is successful I have documentation
for the function that's in my you may
see module if I hit build then oh it's
all up to date
but if I hit ctrl f5 and run then we'll
get in to the basic benchmark program so
tan H which some of you are familiar
with some probably not doesn't really
matter it's a slightly interesting
calculation that's not always built-in I
have three different ways of running it
a lot of times and adding it to the list
so two seconds doing it that way about
1.8 seconds using the map function to do
it instead finally I'm using the C
extension so importing the function that
I wrote and running that annual said
significantly faster simply by taking
basic code porting it into C and then
calling it from Python rather than
writing it in Python itself but what
happens when that doesn't work this is
where Visual Studio has its feature that
no one else has and it's really exciting
because the Salling doesn't work in
Python code then typically you're going
to hit a breakpoint you'll say oh I want
to stop at that breakpoint there and
then you'll run your step step step
hover over variables and see what they
are and figure out why it's not working
but what if you're running Python code
and the air is actually in the C code
and what I really want to do is go over
to this function and say uh let me set a
breakpoint here in C and I'll go back to
my Python project and run it and see why
it's broken
and the support that we have here
actually allows you to do that so rather
than I've done basically nothing
different here I'll show you the magic
trick in a sec and we skip that first
test and now I'm not to see extension
tests we're going to do if I snapped an
H again and this time we hit the
breakpoint and we're in the C function
and if I look at the call stack then
you'll see if you look at the language
column down the right-hand side
we're in C but we came from Python so if
I jump back up here then I'm in Python I
can see all the same variables that I
could see in Python code and I can jump
back down and now I'm in the C code and
I can see everything that would have
been seen in C code before so we have
this multiple points of view over the
same bit of code jumping from python
code into c code c code back into python
code no matter which order we're able to
track it down identify which parts of
the call stack belong to which one and
give you the right view for the right
place so if you are working and c
extension modules at all even if you're
working in site then it's possible to do
this as well and instead of being in the
c code you can actually go back to the
safe and source code and see and fully
debug everything as you're working
through in both languages the trick here
is in the Python project this is this is
not much of a trick of the honest in the
properties for the project under the bug
there's a simple checkbox enable native
code debugging there's a lot of caveats
extra requirements extra benefits to
doing this or not doing it so it's we
want to offer it as a choice because
sometimes it's better not to have this
turned on sometimes it's better to have
this turned on even if you're not
actually debugging any C code because
it's going to be less impactful on your
Python code it's entirely possible that
if you have something in your python
code that's setting up its own debugger
or its own tracing then add the bug and
might interfere but if you're enable
native code debugging you can bypass
that and you still get some Python
debugging without interfering with that
kind of extra code
so that's one of our really cool unique
features that we have and of course all
the rest of the debugging support is
there if you want conditional
breakpoints we do those you can break
after a breakpoint has been hit a
certain number of times there's a lot of
configuration options that are just
available for all languages in vs and
that includes Python I want to move on
to our before we run out of time does
anyone have any python questions
anything you really want to know that I
didn't talk about
but I was cleaning around the back
yeah it's currently not enabled for
Visual Studio code that is something
that we are looking to improve over time
so yeah so the question is essentially
Visual Studio code has like a different
set of support from Visual Studio in
this case and right now yeah they're
different products they have they're at
different levels in different areas
Visual Studio code has some better stuff
in some places Visual Studio has some
better stuff in some places specifically
package management and PIP support is a
little further ahead in Visual Studio
than Visual Studio code and you know the
plan is to you know get them both up to
the same level we want all of our IDs to
be you know fully supporting the
language as much as possible so yeah
right now
Visual Studio code is best served by
jumping into the terminal and you know
doing pip install whatever from there
but we're hoping that it will get up to
some better integration than it
currently has anything else all right
let's look at some are so who are the
eye users in the room who uses our Antal
the people who use the shiney no one who
knows about Shanee who wants to use
shiny what is shiny okay so I'm going to
grab this shiny movies solution that's
also in the repository so if you've
cloned it and you can open this as well
if you've got the our support installed
shiny is basically a really easy way to
make interactive websites around your
data set so I'll just ignore that for a
bit wallet loads so if you have a data
set and in this case we're using I think
it's a run Tomatoes movie database that
you have you want to do some actual
interactive analysis on you want to do
filtering lives and you don't just want
to sit at the interactive thing or if
you want to give that data set and that
view of it to someone else who doesn't
want to sit at an interactive prompt
doing all of this stuff by hand because
you know they're a manager then you can
give them something wrapped up in the
shiny web app that's going to
be very easy to use very visually
appealing and very easy to create
so if I jump into the solution here let
me get it started and so run up is the
one magic command that I've got to run
and believe that our interactive window
is showing progress yeah this has I'll
jump into the code for it in a little
bit but this is going to take you know a
straightforward UI and it'll I think it
will impress you with you the
interactivity and just a response that's
involved here or just running inside the
browser so that's going to spin up my
browser and see it's a local that was
not the right error that I wanted I
didn't want an arrow at all to be honest
yes
okay let's try that again
packages should be installed already
right
I was just waking up being paying all
this attention to Python and not me okay
apparently we're not
I want this to work cause I have to fall
back to my other our demo it's nowhere
near as pretty so but I might have to
while we're working on that let me pull
up the UI so if you've ever done HTML
and JavaScript you probably wished it
looked more like this when I show you
the actual page running you'll be very
disappointed that it doesn't look more
like this but we are making an explorer
page with a couple of sliders you see
slider input shows up a few times I've
really got to fix that red color and
essentially a plot that's going to show
the the data that we've filtered down
with a couple of filters that we have
and is that okay it's going to it's
going to plot out the data we've
selected and filter down and hopefully
if this does start this time then forget
I wonder if something updated between
when I last tried this
nope looks like we're not getting that
today okay
full back is to let's open this back up
in the folder view
and I'm going to open up this Vince
flood thing let me spread that out again
reset this so again this file is in the
script folder of the repository that you
cloned earlier so if you'd like to work
through it you can and this is
essentially just a demo of a handful of
our plots I'm going to grab all of it
and run it all at once when we've gotten
started here
as an absolute fallback I can jump to a
video that I was given of the demo see
that's a good idea
yeah okay so instead of doing the shiny
thing I'm just going to run a whole lot
of plots so we did some plots earlier in
Python if you've used that then you'll
be familiar with it's got some really
good ways of generating a whole lot of
plots but if you use to a studio then
you might generate a whole lot of plots
and go Oh what just happened they've all
gone I've only got the most recent one
left and that's something that we've
added to an Visual Studio that I feel
like I'm not going to have a lot of luck
with our today this is
anyway
the joys of running in preview software
let's try that one again
okay
going to run everything in my our
interactive window I hoped
I don't know that I'm going to have any
luck without today I'm very sorry about
that as you'll notice there's a nice big
preview banner in the top row of my
visual studio I am using one of the
latest release version oh here we are
we're going somewhere yes yes delete it
doing that okay
we have let me run everything all at
once there we go okay and so now we're
getting plots showing up just plot after
plot this is just one big pile of demos
you can go through it one by one in your
own time I'm just going to run all of
them just to give you an overview of how
pretty the plots are now in any normal
sort of environment that's it and you've
seen all the plots and if you want an
earlier one you go back and rerun it
again we have a plot history window
which is really really cool that's going
to give you an overview of all the
previous plots and lets you bring any of
them back up again by double clicking
and we've actually kept enough
information there that we can re render
the plots in for a new size if you are
changing the windows so if you have
everything small and then decide oh I
actually need to see that bigger more
clearly you can go back and bring that
up and adjust the size see the plot
again you can zoom in or out on these if
you like this is I really quite like
this view for a whole lot of demos let
me give SHINee another go well yeah you
know go it with a bang
there's yeah so our tools also comes
with the ability to write to connect
your our engine so it's obviously
running against an instance of our exe
somewhere you can be running that on a
totally different machine rather than
your own so it is possible to use our
from Visual Studio without ever actually
installing our on your local machine you
can remote into another machine to do
that I don't have enough of a setup
right now to demonstrate that there are
demos online so I'd recommend looking
those up come chat to us afterwards we
can point you towards those if you're
interested let me give Shanee one more
go and while that's running does anyone
have any questions about the Python
support or the our support yes as an
adjust the parameters for the plot it's
certainly something to consider for the
future it doesn't currently allow that
so ah nope and I have no shiney sorry
we'll have Matt instead
- what okay I don't have that I don't
think I have that on here
no such anyone I have it worked earlier
I mean we did we tried it like two hours
ago maybe
yeah okay so that is a quick run around
Visual Studio probably the deepest dive
into the configuration options you've
ever seen or will ever see anywhere as I
said at the start my hope for that is
that when you find yourself being
offered Visual Studio or being
encouraged to use it for whatever reason
you don't have to spend five minutes in
it go I can't figure out how to use this
at all this makes no sense this doesn't
behave the way I want it to this does
everything wrong I hope now that you've
got some better idea of where you can go
to fix it where you can go to improve it
and ways to look up online other ideas
about how to change it extensions that
may be useful again if you're used to
them a lot of vim users love the VSM
extension certainly a lot of Python
developers love the indent guides
extension it's very helpful for that as
extensions for basically everything if
you have any more questions I'm happy to
take a few now if not I'll be around for
the entire conference feel free to come
and find me and I can give you more
demos or we can chat more about anything
you like so if there's no questions now
thank you yep are there any features to
help type in running on a show there's a
few there's a few well we're actively
working on a whole lot of those right
now support for publishing projects - as
your app service is roughly there
there's a few extra steps but there is
documentation that will help you work
through that you can certainly run
Python on any of the virtual machine
setups on Azure where if you want to be
running it on a Windows machine or a
Linux machine all of those are you know
you get a plain virtual machine you can
run whatever you like cloud service we
have some templates to help with that's
kind of the partially managed virtual
machines service as your machine
learning has some Python integration if
you're at the very sort of high level of
I have some data coming in I just want
to do a transform on that with Python
before analyzing it in some other way
Python functions you can make work
you're going to demo the rest we have a
successful shiny demo so we're about to
switch to that on the screen if you want
to watch that what
a lot of azure services that we're
bringing up for patient
and right now I believe Python actually
has the best coverage for the azure
management libraries so if you're trying
to automate deployments to Azure the
command line tool is written in Python
which means the Python library for Azure
is one of the most fully fleshed out
that's available and there's a number of
teams working on their client libraries
so you can certainly access a lot of as
your stuff from Python now and we're
working on a range of other features
somebody's analyst or data scientist
officially create a visually pleasing a
UI or the very complex work and model of
whatever that they feel that they can
share with other people so here
basically the Chinese tell me the UI
heart and Observer are and just what are
you ready could we do this information
so this is what I was attempting to run
that's exactly the same it's exactly the
same code on a note they can't hear you
won't be on the video this is the same
shiny app that I was tryna run you can
see there's a number of filters on the
size drop-down text search things and
then we have a plot of basically all the
data points that meet those filters so
as we drag around the year of release or
filter down the genre you'll see a
number of points disappear if you hover
over any of those points then you'll see
the title or you see the like some of
the information about that data point
that's not otherwise represented in the
graph again the color is different based
on one of the properties so you can do
all of this with a very small amount of
code using shiny and there's a number of
libraries that can do similar things
from Python point of view this is very
much an active area in terms of how do
we take data and visualize in some
useful way for a range of people what
we're showing here from visual studio is
really just demoing shiny so if you
develop this in visual studio debugger
and visual studio and then take it and
deploy it to anyone that run shiny it's
going to work totally fine this doesn't
have any Microsoft specific stuff in it
at all this is our
supported and being run from within our
tools not our being you know embraced
and extinguished by Microsoft this is
where enabling the use of these tools
that already exists not already out
there from with individuals to do
exactly the same way with Python we
don't have our own special Python we're
supporting and enabling other versions
of Python we don't have our own package
manager or enabling pip or eventually
enabling Condor this is a general theme
at the moment especially with Visual
Studio in general is going this way
certainly the Python I support has
always been this way bring your own path
and bring your own are do whatever your
work needs to be we want to help you to
do your best work
whatever that is wherever it's going and
really just enable you to get your best
work done so we're now out of time thank
you everyone for coming in today I hope
you've learned something I hope you
enjoy the rest of Pi data and see around